In the last video I learned about myosin and more specifically
myosin II - it has two myosin heads,
and their tails are intertwined
with each other. We have learned how myosin II can use the ATP molecule,
to attract an actin thread
or to move on.
At first it is attached.
It then binds the ATP molecule.
This makes him separate.
The ATP molecule is then hydrolyzed in ADP and a phosphate group.
When this happens, energy is released.
The energy level is rising.
This stretches the protein as a spring
and myosin II attaches another groove to the actin thread,
after which the phosphate group leaves and then the conformational change
in protein is sufficient.
Generated pressure force on
the actin thread to move
myosin and the one to which it is attached,
left and right.
In the next videos, we'll talk about what
is myosin.
Surely your heads are born
a few questions.
Myosin makes a great effort to attract the thread.
There is tension that pulls in the opposite direction.
The muscles are so. There should be
weight or other resistance.
What happens when the thread is released?
In the first step, when the ATP molecule joins and that
here is released, the active thread is not simple
to shrink back,
especially if there is tension
in the opposite direction?
The answer is simple: This is not the only protein myosin,
which acts on the actin.
There are others along the chain.
There may be one.
Like here.
They work at their own pace at different times.
They are many when one of them
is granted, another may apply
force or be active.
Therefore, if suddenly a myosin
free the actin thread, it will not be
shrink back.
The other question you might ask is:
How do I turn it off and on?
We command our muscles,
so what turns the myosin system on and off,
who moves on the actin?
To understand this, there are two more proteins,
which act.
Tropomyosin and troponin.
I'll make a rough painting on
the actin thread.
This is an actin thread with its
grooves.
Its structure is spiral.
The grooves are also spiral,
but this is not important now.
In the previous video, we painted proteins
myosin.
They may resemble your feet or heads, which
are constantly attached to the thread. Then based on where they are
in the ATP cycle, are constantly shrinking
or tightening as a spring and moving forward by pushing.
We have on the thread
protein tropomyosin.
It wraps around the acta.
This is the actin.
This is one of the two chapters of myosin II.
And this is tropomyosin.
It is wrapped around the acta.
The drawing is very rough, but you can imagine
how it wraps and passes behind it and then in the front,
then back again and so on.
The important thing about it is the following.
In fact, I'm going back.
It is wrapped around the actin and is attached to it
with another protein called the troponin.
For example, it is attached to a troponin
Here, here, this is not very accurate,
and here.
I will write it.
The Troponin crashes
like nails in acta.
It determines where tropomyosin is located.
When the muscle is at rest, it turns out
tropomyosin blocks myosin.
I have read a lot on the subject,
that this is still being investigated.
It is not yet clear.
Tropomyosin blocks myosin
to attach to its usual places
by the acta so that it can not move along the thread
or when the myosin is attached to the actin,
tropomyosin does not allow him to move
and sliding on the actin.
We can conclude that tropomyosin
block myosin head - here it is,
so that it can not move through the acta like
physically blocks the binding site, or if it is already connected,
prevents her from moving along the thread.
In any case, she blocks her and she can
to release only if the proteins troponin change
its conformation, i. its shape.
This can only happen if we have
high concentration of calcium ions.
If we have a sufficient concentration
of calcium ions, they
will connect to the troponin and will change
its conformation enough to move
the configuration of tropomyosin.
I will write it.
Usually, tropomyosin blocks, but when we have it
high concentration of calcium ions they bind
with the troponin and altering
his conformation, and so he displaces the tropomyosin.
Following the shift of tropomyosin,
high calcium concentration and trompone binding,
as we talked in the last clip,
myosin heads may begin to move
by acta or pushing it
to the right.
But if the concentration of calcium falls,
calcium ions will be released from the troponin.
Always have enough calcium ions attached.
If the concentration drops dramatically, these ions
will begin to separate. Then the Troponin will be
regain the standard conformation.
Thus, tropomyosin will again block myosin.
I can not say the explanations here
were simple.
It was discovered only 50-60 years ago
and all this is monitored
proven by experiments to understand,
but the very idea is simple.
Without calcium, tropomyosin blocked
the ability of the myosin to attach there where necessary,
or to move on the actin, i. to push it.
But if the concentration of calcium is high enough,
he will connect to the troponin,
thus "nailing" the tropomyosin, wrapped around the actin,
and when the trompamine changes its conformation
with calcium ions, he shifts the tropomyosin,
to allow the myosin to move.
That's how we build a way
to cut our muscles and
to control these redundancies.
If there is a high concentration of calcium in the cell,
the muscle will be shortened.
If the concentration drops again,
he will immediately relax.
The myosin will be blocked and the muscle will relax again.